[Music]
and i'm really
also really interested in bs sleep i've
actually started playing around with it
a tiny bit before uh in the previous
project i think there's a lot of
potential there
uh for my presentation today i was i
would actually like
to uh talk to you more about
how do you actually do custom solutions
so uh
it's very common in shining that you end
up having to
create custom components create custom
widgets that
you end up having to style them again
but
because they aren't
there's no package for them there's
there's not part of base shiny
uh you end up having to do your own
custom styling
uh so with that uh we can get started
and i will just uh quick introduction
about me i've been a shiny developer
with upland for
closing in on three years now uh before
that i was a web developer for
the better part of eight years so
there's a lot of a lot of the skills
that i actually got as a web developer
kind of translate very well into shiny
uh and also i'm an
open source creator and contributor uh
with epsilon as well
and you can reach me in any of those
social medias so if you
if you'd like to check out my codes uh
take a look at github if you just have a
question or would like to get in touch
you can also reach me so for today i
will
give you a small introduction of what
css is in case you don't know
i will also talk about the different
ways that you can actually edit shiny
i will talk a bit about sas and sas
a package from our studio i'll give you
a short introduction just get you
started
and also how you can use it to change uh
so like a very quick uh introduction the
crash course to css
what is it uh so css is basically uh
how the internet uh describes
the way that elements are displayed on a
page
basically it lets you control uh
multiple elements by the usage of
classes and selectors um and basically
it's
made of very small instructions which
are called statements
statements do simply two things so
they identify an object in the page
and they declare a value for a specific
property of that element
so this is a very simple example of what
a css
statement would look like so you can see
that we're styling something that
has a class of search box and we're
styling the border in the back
the background of that specific element
the cool thing with css is that if you
have two elements or 10 elements or 50
elements with this specific class
they will all be affected by by this
specific rule
uh so why is this really important for
shiny uh the thing is every web page
right now in some way or another uses
css
and chinese is no exception so even
though
you're programming in aria and you're
building this shiny application
uh behind the scenes what's actually
happening is that shiny is generating
some javascript some html some css
and the key part here is the css so
because
uh some css is being generated we can
also add our own
on top of it so how would we
actually go about doing this so uh with
chinese itself there's
three uh very specific ways that you can
do it
uh so you can add the style directly to
your targets when you're building your
ui
uh you can add it as a let's say a
separate
tag in the header of your page or your
application
uh but you can also store it in files
and link those files directly to
the shiny application so for the first
one
whatever you create in your ui as long
as it's an html tag
you can always pass a special style
attributes
which lets you basically pass any kind
of
uh css statement that will affect that
specific
element so here there's no uh statements
there's no classes there's nothing this
is style that you want to apply to that
specific
uh to that specific element
and uh this is fine
this is okay but uh to be honest this is
probably this should be your last resort
when it comes to adding
css to shiny the the truth is that uh
by adding it's fine if you have one or
two elements but when you get to 10 20
50 elements when you start having very
complex uis
uh you lose track of where you style the
specific thing
uh you cannot reuse any any rules so if
you have three titles you need to style
the three titles
uh it's very hard to keep consistency
between all the
all the elements this is something that
if you use via sleep for example it's
solved for you because it's uh
there's general rules that affect every
element but if you're doing these
individual changes you won't be able to
actually
keep track of them as as your project
grows
the second way would be to add css to
your header so
this is slightly better this is uh
you can add a style tag uh with some
some text inside and that text can be
css text uh this is slightly better
uh this does mean that you can use those
selectors you can
you can apply the same styling to a lot
of elements at the same time
but at the same time you won't really be
able to
leverage the browser here because
because you're generating this css
whenever the page is created
this actually means that uh your browser
won't be able to cache these
so and by caching i mean saving them for
future usage when you
reopen the application later so you end
up
having a slightly better approach but at
the same time it's still not the ideal
approach
so we can always do the third option so
this would be
to create a style to create a file with
all of our css
on the side uh link this file to our
shiny application
and then the browser actually has
something that
it can save for the future and at the
same time we have
a specific place where we have all our
styling neatly
saved packed away from our code from our
logic
uh this is this is much better this is
probably the
the best uh the best approach you can
take if you're using just
regular css uh you can reuse the code
you can reuse the
the rules uh you can cache these files
uh
your browser can leverage the cache to
actually save these files for later
uh it also allows you to kind of
separate
your styling into multiple files and
start adding a bit of structure to to
how you're
saving styling for different elements
for different modules
uh however css is still something that
can get
very complex and it's kind of this thing
that grows out of control very fast as
your project grows
so there's still a bit of room for
improvement here
uh so one way that you can
improve this workflow even better is to
use stats so
sas is as tom mentioned before
this is a a language built on top of css
and the idea here is that it's a
preprocessor to css so it
any any sas that you create always ends
up
being css but there's this layer of
abstraction where
you have a few different tools then you
don't really need to worry about
creating very complex or managing very
complex css because
sas gives you a couple of ways of
managing it a bit better
so a couple of differences here between
size and css
are celsius object oriented so this
means that
you can have nesting it's more about the
concept of what is
a specific element that you're trying to
target not the specific element that
you're targeting
it also allows variables i know that
css3 is actually
pushing forward with variables in css
this is
uh i think a very nice bonus but
it's one of the things that uh sus at
least my understanding still does
much better than just css and also you
can always use us to actually generate
css
variables to trees in the future
um so a couple of uh really
interesting things that you can do with
sas so we talked about
nesting so what nesting means is that
you can simplify a lot of the rules that
you do
by nesting them so as you can see css
doesn't css on the right side doesn't
really allow for this
so if you're targeting two different
elements in this case for example a ul
and an ally element inside of a nav bar
you're going to need to create the full
selector every time
you you create a rule sus kind of solves
this by allowing nesting so
if you have two elements inside the same
the same elements you can kind of nest
them together
and simplify your code even a tiny bit
more
we also talked about variables so css
does allow variables but sas does it in
a way that you can
kind of declare them even in separate
files completely different there is
no scope required which is something
that css variables need
and you can simply use them by assigning
a name to a property that starts with a
dollar sign and then just this becomes a
variable that you can use throughout
your code
it also has the i it also has two
very important mechanisms which are
extends and mixing so extends this kind
of
uh and this is something that is very
well explained with an example so
uh it basically allows you to share uh
styles between selectors
and the way that you would do this
normally in css if you would have
two elements that you would like to
style even though they are very similar
is that you would simply do the styling
for both of them
uh by using extend you can actually
create
a partial part of code by using the the
percentage
as as um as a marker for the name of
that
block of code and you can then extend
for each element you can simply extend
the name the the extend rule that you
created
and the code will actually be copied
into that selected so this means that
you can
reuse uh parts of styling that you use
very often
by simply uh extracting them
into a separate name that you can then
reuse
uh the second one is mixins so mixins
are
slightly similar but these you these
work more like functions so the the idea
here is that
uh instead of simply taking out a piece
of a block of code
and saving it with a name uh with a mix
and you're actually having a function so
this means that you can
pass specific arguments to those
functions that you're creating
so in this case for example uh we've
identified that the only difference
between these two components is actually
the border size
so we can create a mixin that has an
argument of border size and simply call
those functions
in each of our declarations for each
specific element
um so small introduction of sas
very big a very crash coursy kind of
thing but
hopefully it shows you uh some of the
advantages that you actually have
so uh how do you actually use this with
with r
so the the the best way is of course to
use a library and our studio was kind
enough to actually create
a really nice package for for us so you
can
you can uh use our sauce
to not have to worry about all the
pre-processing you just need to write
code
this is all you want to do and in
general uh
the package gives you one big function
called sas
and this sas function can take take
either a string
or a full file and just returns the css
to you so all of these
uh all of these techniques that we've
been talking about you know i've
accessed them inside of
our uh directly without without having
to
to uh without actually having to
to work outside of of
our files uh the second way is actually
you can actually pass it a reference to
a file so here for example we're simply
pointing the sas function to our styles
main file
and this file has a lot of internal
stuff for sas
and this way you can kind of
file all of your you can kind of split
all of your styling
into something that behaves a bit more
like code managing
and actually lets you reuse a lot of the
styles and kind of keep
a grasp of styles when it comes to very
big projects
a second argument that's very important
in this function is the output so the
output will generate that
css to a specific file and then this is
something that you can simply add to
your ui
and now you have your all of your styles
saved in a project uh in a
a project a folder structure that has
everything well
sorted and you can kind of manage them
uh
if you would like to see an example of
sas being used
uh very extensively i will point you to
my
uh shiny contest entry from last year
used us quite a lot and hopefully
it will guide you in the right way to
get started
uh yeah and i think my 15 minutes are up
and i'll just like to thank you for this
and i also i know that the slides will
be available later so i've also added a
couple of
resources here to to get you started
with sas
and in case you really want to get
into css there's also a couple of bonus
slides with
some of the selectors that uh i
i think are the the at least the basic
ones that you
you need to know for c for css so
hopefully this will
get you started and in one year you'll
be thinking
uh how have i been using css without sus
let's talk about speeding up shiny apps
so small disclaimer this is going to be
just some of the the
i think very important details that you
always need to take care of
uh it doesn't mean that you'll be able
to speed up
everything using just these tips um
but hopefully it will get you started uh
when attempts to at least identify some
of the the issues that you're
shining up might have so i'm going to
talk about three
very important details when it comes to
speeding up training applications
the first one is update functions i'll
also talk a bit about
proxy objects and proxy functions
and then i will finish up by letting you
know a bit about custom messages and
browser offloading i won't get into
too much detail and of course every
package is different and it is
needs different types of optimizations
but hopefully this will
help you get started so update functions
what
what are update functions uh so
update functions are very simple
functions
that let's let you update existing
shiny widgets so the important thing
here is that
uh bass shiny has these uh but it's
very possible that you're not always
using them
so uh as an example we have a very
we have here a very simple shiny
application that has just a checkbox and
a drop down
and you can see that in our ui we define
a checkbox and we define a ui output and
then
in our server we simply observe that a
checkbox
and we change our select input label and
values
uh depending on on the uh
the state of the checkbox this feels
very standard this is the
simple this is something that you
probably did
quite a lot of times already however
you can see that we're not really using
any update functions
so what do i mean by that what's
happening here is that
every time we trigger a change with the
checkbox we're actually re-rendering the
drop-down
so you can see that uh because we're
using a ui output
and then filling in that ui output with
our drop down
uh what's actually happening behind the
scenes is that
whenever this output changes shine is
removing
all the the bindings that it created in
the background
it creates a new set of bindings for a
new drop down that just hands a
it does have the same id but it's a
completely new drop down
and has to rebuild the whole structure
uh
so this we can probably do better here
and this is where update functions come
in so if we
simply uh change
our codes to instead of using a ui
output
to simply render a select input and then
instead of filling in the ui output we
simply use
the update select input function uh
this is completely different so in this
case what's happening is that there's a
call from shiny
being sent to the browser that says
hey update this specific input
that already exists in the browser uh
with
a new label and some new values
so you can see here that these are very
small changes
but uh it's already
[Music]
a slightly different approach to how
we're actually building the application
uh but does this really matter and
just to give you an example of how uh
what kind of improvements we're talking
about
the difference even for this simple
drop down is actually that's for the
page to be completely re-rendered and
ready for the user to use
there's a it goes down from 15
milliseconds to 10 milliseconds
so just a simple and we're not even
talking about the very complex
uh thing that we're doing here it's just
a simple drop down
uh it's already a massive improvement so
you can you can
imagine that if we're talking about 50
drop downs 50 elements that we're
re-rendering
these really add up add up very quickly
uh so why is this actually better uh
like i said the update function is
actually just
sending a message to the browser and
then updating
that specific element so there's no need
to rebuild anything it just uses the
bindings that
shiny already created for that specific
element
when it comes to update functions these
are present in
most shiny widgets out of the box so if
you're using even just bass shiny
any kind of input that you create it
probably has
a corresponding update function so
action buttons
uh always have an update action button
select input always have an update
select input and you can see here that
there's a bit of a standard
where the update function is always
uh the name of the ui definition of the
the widget
with a pre prefix update
uh of course always make sure to check
the
documentation usually these are linked
in the bottom
uh after the the the function definition
you have
some information about what kind of
updates actually exist and what kind of
arguments can actually be updated with
that function
so these update functions are nice but
what happens when we have slightly more
complex switches and this is the case
of when you have for example a dt table
or an
e-charts chart or a leaflet mod these
usually work slightly different because
we're talking about very complex
uh very complex widgets that
a simple update function is probably not
enough for
for everything so this is where proxies
come in so
proxies are basically a way to reference
an existing widget an existing complex
widget
and then usually they have their own set
of functions that behave
similar to update functions
but are applied to that specific instant
instant proxy instance of the the widget
itself
so uh a lot of what usually happens
is that uh an example is dt so
um you render you create your data table
output
you fill it in with render data table
it creates a table uh by using
the way to access the proxy to that
element that we just created
is actually to use data table proxy so
this is a function that also exists in
dte
and lets you save a reference to a
specific table with a specific id that
was defined
somewhere else in this case it uses the
same
id as the data table output
and you can see that this is
basically an example of how you could
use proxy so
we define our data table output we
fill it in with our render table and
some in this case the iris data set
and then if we save the
reference to the proxy of that element
using data table proxy we can just
manipulate it so
in this case we have a small check box
and every time the check box changes we
call
a specific proxy update function which
in this case is select rows and we just
select or not don't select the first
five rows of the table
uh exactly um
so one important thing to know here is
that uh different packages
also have different update functions so
it's important to know
to figure out these functions whenever
you need to use them
again documentation is always your
friend so
if you if you check for this data table
proxy function you'll have a lot of
information about
all the update functions that come with
that proxy object
and internally proxy actually works very
similar
to the update functions that i mentioned
before
the the difference here is that instead
of having one update function
we actually have a family of update
functions and an
object to apply it to
um again
it's important to check the
documentation you won't always be able
to
update every single thing uh so
there is it's very important to know the
family of
proxy update functions that exist uh
hopefully there will be one that does
what you need it to do
if not we'll probably
we'll actually talk about it uh now
which is
uh custom messages so if something
doesn't really exist uh you can always
create it
and this is part of the beauty of shiny
uh generating that html css and
javascript that we were talking about
before
because the fact that deep down
uh you're still working with a web page
means that you can
use uh javascript by itself to actually
augment china even more so what are
custom messages uh so
when i mention the update functions the
update functions are basically a one-way
call to the browser where internally
there's some codes being run
something that you don't really know but
you know that it's going to trigger
something in the browser
and update it what's actually happening
down there is
similar to how custom messages work so
you can trigger javascript functions
from r
directly or you can let
or you can trigger updates in shiny from
the browser
there's three three functions that kind
of
give you the whole uh behavior of
customer messages so in
r this is the send custom message
function in javascript this is the
add custom message handler and the on
input
change functions so uh
i will give you another example of of
shiny decisions my uh my shiny contest
entry from last year so one of the
things that i had to do was
i had the leaflet map that was sorry
i had a leaflet map that was displaying
some some markers it was being updated
that's fine there's always that there's
an update function for leaflet that lets
me change the data that way
but i wanted to have this extra behavior
of
actually changing the saturation of
the map depending on how bad you're
you're actually doing in the game so i
this isn't something that is standard to
leaflet this
this had to be custom built and this is
where custom messages kind of came in
so uh from the javascript side remember
there's
uh the add custom messenger ms
head custom message handler function and
basically what this does is it lets you
run a function whenever a specific
id is triggered in shiny so what i mean
by that
is that it kind of registers
the handler so that it can be triggered
from shiny so in this case i have this
update map style handler
that will call this update map style
function and the update map
function will just it will create some
css that kind of gives you that
that that
sepia filter that gets a bit more uh
evident whenever the your scores are
very low in the game
or it goes up whenever and goes back to
the normal colors whenever you're doing
better
so now we have some javascript behavior
and we have a shiny handler
to trigger that behavior so on the our
side we just need to send the custom
message for the same id
with whatever values we want to pass to
the
to the javascript function so two simple
functions
and we already have a leaflet behavior
that
doesn't really exist before uh
as the as a very small proof of concept
the way this is actually working is that
from our the way the all flow works is
that from
r you're sending a custom message that
custom message
is looking for a specific handler that
handler is triggering a specific
javascript function that's it
there's there's no message and there's
no magic here so
now we can from shiny trigger things in
javascript
uh but what happens if we
we want to do uh the opposite thing so
we we actually want to and i just
realized these are actually
traded so the first one is actually
javascript the second one is actually
shiny so if we have a javascript
function that's doing some work in the
browser
uh how do we actually tell shiny that
something is happening
that something happened so we can use
this set input value so this set input
value works very similar
it has an id and a message and what it
does is that
it sends a message to shiny that can be
observable in the list of inputs
in the shiny session so this means that
our input.js value
will actually be changed into the
message that we pass
from javascript so we can just observe
it
uh do whatever we need so now we can
pass messages from the browser
back to shine and
another example of something that uses
this kind of behavior in the same
application so
here i was observing whenever the user
made a choice
and then i was just sending using this
set
input value so that i could observe it
in shiny and actually know that
something changed
so why are these important when it comes
to speeding up shiny so
because these allow you to actually pass
a lot of the
to run whatever you want directly in the
browser this means that you can
free your shiny process to actually do
only the important things so if you have
very small
uh very small changes that are just ui
changes
and don't really need to go to the
server this is one way that you can
trigger them
it also means that if you have some kind
of code that already exists in
javascript
you can actually just trigger that code
instead of having to rebuild it in
chinese so this
this speeds up not only shiny itself but
actually
the shiny development because you won't
need to just redo
the same function again in a different
language
it also allows you to extend these
update functions that we talked about
before simply because there's
uh there's no there's no need
to write a corresponding shiny function
a corresponding update function
if this is something very specific to
your application so
it's very easy to get started and very
powerful
uh of course keep in mind that you will
need to know a bit of javascript at
least to get started
but if you don't know it by now i
definitely recommend you to at least
know some of the basics because it's
very very powerful when it comes to
training
and that's it from my part thank you
if you have any questions just reach out